Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Der Fußball hat seine Panama Papers, die Football Leaks. Was das bedeutet, was das alles noch bringen könnte und wie die ganze Sache eigentlich zustande kam, das erzählt mir Christoph Henrichs vom Spiegel. Christoph, ich grüße dich. Schön, dass du Zeit gefunden hast in dieser arbeitsreichen Phase deines Lebens.
Ja, herzlichen Dank für die Einladung. Freut mich, das erste Mal hier im Rasenfunk dabei zu sein. Es ist eine große Ehre.
Ja und dann gleich zu so einem Thema. Ich vermute, ich lehne mich nicht weit aus dem Fenster, wenn ich sage, du hast gerade eher zu viel als zu wenig zu tun.
Ja, das könnte man wohl so sagen. Wir haben letzte Woche ja das erste Heft rausgehauen, den Auftakt zu Footballleaks. Wir hatten dann am Freitagabend, als wir dann tatsächlich nur noch darauf warteten, dass auf Spiegel Online das Projekt dann auch online ging und wir dann auch auf die ersten Reaktionen warten konnten, das Gefühl, jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Jetzt haben wir den großen Aufschlag hingelegt und dann ist erstmal so ganz viel Druck von uns abgefallen und Ananenlinen und so weiter und jetzt auf einmal diese Woche merken wir, es geht ja genauso weiter, wenn nicht sogar schlimmer, weil jetzt weiß die ganze Welt von diesem Projekt und jetzt gibt es Reaktionen und jetzt passiert ganz viel, während wir auch noch weiterarbeiten und jetzt auch noch mitten in der Produktion zum neuen Heft stehen.
Ja, und dann ruft halt auch noch der Max vom Rasenfunk an. Umso schöner, dass das wirklich geklappt hat. Wir wollen mal ein bisschen über dieses Thema reden, das meiner Meinung nach eines der wichtigsten Themen vielleicht sogar der nächsten Jahre werden könnte im Fußball. Das werden wir jetzt gleich mal diskutieren. Aber um mal auch die Hörer abzuholen, die das bisher so vielleicht am Rande mitbekommen haben, versuch doch mal, so schwierig es ist, in ein paar Sätzen zu sagen, was sind denn eigentlich die Footballleaks? Worum geht es?
Die Footballleaks haben begonnen als einen Blog. Das sind, wir nennen es mal Aktivisten, die die Wahrheit über die Fußballwelt, über die Fußballbranche an die Öffentlichkeit bringen wollen. Und sie haben einige Verträge veröffentlicht zum Beispiel und hatten da aber nicht so den durchschlagenden Erfolg, dass wirklich alle Footballfans oder auch, ich sag mal, Mainstream-Medien, die nicht irgendwie nur auf Fußball spezialisiert sind, das aufgenommen haben. Und dann hat mein Kollege Rafael Buschmann mit ihren Machern von Footballleaks Kontakt aufgenommen und nach vielen Gesprächen über verschlüsselte Kanäle und nach einigen Treffen hat er dann eine gewaltige Datenmenge bekommen. Das sind 1,9 Terabyte. Das kann man sich gar nicht so gut vorstellen, wie viel das eigentlich ist. Also wenn man mal überlegt, wie viel man so auf seiner eigenen Festplatte hat und was davon vielleicht große Videodateien oder MP3-Dateien sind, das sind alles Dokumente und E-Mails und Excel-Tabellen und PDF-Dateien. Wir hatten jetzt immer so diesen vielleicht etwas schieben oder schwierigen Vergleich mit den 500.000 Bibeln, dem diese Textmenge, die wir hier zu verarbeiten hatten, entspricht. Ich habe auch noch mal gelesen, vielleicht wäre ein passender Vergleich gewesen, wie viele DIN-A-Vierseiten man auf einem Fußballfeld hätte drucken können.
Ah, dann hätte man den berühmten Fußballfeld-Vergleich mit drin gehabt.
Da kann man sich auch nicht mehr vorstellen dann letztendlich. Also es ist einfach eine Menge, die jeglicher Vorstellungskraft entfleucht. Und da saßen wir dann irgendwann vor, vor sieben Monaten und haben überlegt, was machen wir jetzt damit.
Aber das heißt, im Grunde geht es erstmal darum, das ist eine Menge an Daten, da schafft man es nicht mehr, das von Seite 1 bis Seite 1.697.304 durchzulesen, sondern man muss das irgendwie anders scannen. Wie ihr das gemacht habt, das würde mich gleich mal interessieren, aber erstmal, sag nochmal, du hast so angedeutet, Spielerverträge und so weiter. Was sind die Inhalte dieser Daten?
Die Inhalte sind sehr vielfältig und wir wussten natürlich gerade zu Beginn, was da drin steckt in diesem Datenberg, der da vor uns stand. Letztendlich haben wir jetzt mit der ersten Veröffentlichungsreihe, also mit der ersten Veröffentlichung, die wir rausgehauen haben, letzte Woche, uns um Offshore-Konstruktionen gekümmert von Spielern, zum Beispiel von Real Madrid, Cristiano Ronaldo und dem Star-Trainer José Mourinho, der jetzt eher gerade bei Manchester ist. Mesut Özil hatte auch Probleme mit der Steuer, das war aber keine Offshore-Geschichte. Das sind so Sachen, die haben wir aber auch erst Wochen und Monate nachdem wir die Recherche begonnen haben, erst entdeckt. Und dann hat es wieder weitere Wochen und Monate gedauert, bis wir sagen konnten, ach so, okay, das ist tatsächlich die Geschichte und das sind die Systeme und das sind die Strukturen, die sich darin verbergen. Und was sonst noch in den Daten steckt, wie gesagt, ist sehr vielseitig. Wir haben ausführliche Mailwechsel und Kommunikationen von Anwälten, zum Beispiel über diese Offshore-Feller, auch zu anderen Themen und wir haben ganz klassisch Verträge. Verträge aus der Bundesliga, zum Beispiel Verträge zwischen Bundesliga-Vereinen und Spieleragenten, Transfersummen, die da genannt werden und Transfervereinbarungen zwischen zwei Vereinen, die dann sich zum Beispiel um den Spieler, ich sag mal Kevin Volland von der TSG-Hoffenheim zu beiden Cousins kümmern, solche Dinge stecken auch in diesem Datensatz. Und das ist natürlich ein absoluter Goldschatz für Sportjournalisten, die seit Jahren immer wieder diese Sätze hören von den Vereinsverantwortlichen, wir kommentieren keine Zahlen, wir kommentieren keine Abschlusssumme.
Über die Ablösesumme wurde Stillschweigen vereinbart, der berühmte Satz. Ja krass, das heißt, ihr sitzt an sehr, sehr sensiblen Daten. Jetzt hast du schon zweimal oder dreimal das Wort Offshore in den Mund genommen. Erklär mal kurz, was ist damit gemeint, wird ja auch nicht jedem geläufig sein.
Genau, Offshore, denke ich, sind vorherige Leaks bekannt geworden. Es gab ja tatsächlich auch die sogenannten Offshore Leaks und dann auch die Panama Papers zum Beispiel, das waren ähnliche Geschichten. Das sind Steuerparadiese, gerne in der Karibik auf kleinen Inseln, wo kleine Häuser stehen, manchmal sogar nur in einer Hütte, vielleicht mal mit einem zweiten Stockwerk. Und in diesen Hütten, in diesen Klitschen sind Tausende und Abertausende Firmen registriert. Und das machen vorwiegend reiche Leute, weil sie auf diesen Inseln so gut wie keine oder manchmal auch überhaupt keine Steuern zahlen müssen, wenn sie da ihr Geld lagern. Also ein Steuervermeidungsprinzip, in manchen Fällen kann man auch von Steuerhinterziehung sprechen. Und da haben wir tatsächlich die größten Stars in unserer Fußballwelt, die von den meisten Menschen angehimmelt werden, oder die von so vielen Millionen Leuten immer bewundert werden, von denen man die Trikots kauft, die man im Fernsehen sieht und die sich wunderbar inszenieren können. Von denen haben wir festgestellt, die verdienen eine Menge Geld und dann tun sie auch noch eine Menge dafür, dass sie zumindest Teile von diesem Geld nicht versteuern müssen.
Verhalten sich wahrscheinlich letztlich so, wie sich tatsächlich viele Reiche verhalten. Mit dem wachsenden Kontostand wächst nicht immer auch die Bescheidenheit, sondern eher dann das Verlangen, davon wieder möglichst wenig abzugeben. Hat man den Eindruck, wenn man die anderen Leaks, die du schon genannt hast, mit in die Betrachtung einbezieht. Jetzt lass mal kurz darüber reden, was jetzt so die Veröffentlichungen des letzten Samstags jetzt waren, womit ihr jetzt rausgegangen seid. Du hast gesagt, so die größten Spieler, die man so sieht und der Prominentes ist dann natürlich Cristiano Ronaldo.
Genau. Ich denke, das ist auch der größte Spieler unserer Zeit, in dem Sinne, dass auch wirklich jeder eine Meinung zu ihm hat. Er pullt ungemein. Also entweder mag man ihn, weil er so großartig Fußball spielen kann. Ich leg mich da auch selbst immer mit meinem Podcast-Kollegen in Eiltorn fehlt einfach meinem Fußball-Podcast auch an, weil der Cristiano Ronaldo überhaupt nicht ausstehen kann. Aber ich war immer ein Riesenfan von Cristiano Ronaldo und von der Art, wie er Fußball spielt. Und auch wenn jemand überhaupt nichts mit Fußball am Hut hat, dann hat er schon mal Cristiano Ronaldo gesehen und vielleicht erlebt, wie er sich auf einer Bühne gibt oder wofür er alles wirbt und hat eine Meinung über ihn. Und jetzt gucken wir quasi hinter die Fassade und ja auch in die Kontoauszüge von Cristiano Ronaldo. Das ist eine Geschichte, das ist unsere größte Geschichte. In der Geschichte geht es um den Offshore und da spielt auch José Mourinho eine große Rolle. Das wurde übrigens auch in einem sehr digitalen, multimedialen Storytelling auf Spiegel Online weiter erzählt. Dann zwei Tage nach der Veröffentlichung des Hefts mit weiteren Erkenntnissen zu José Mourinho und seinen Steuertricksereien. Genau, das war also der größte Themenkomplex, den wir da hatten. Im ersten Heft hatten wir auch noch die Geschichte über Mesut Özil und seine Probleme mit der Steuer. Dann ging es darum, dass der Verein seinen Spielagenten bezahlt hat, obwohl, nach Auffassung der Steuerbehörden, Mesut Özil das hätte selber tun sollen. Dann geht es in dem Text auch noch um eine außergerichtliche Vereinbarung mit seinem Vater, die sehr merkwürdig aussah. Das ist eine lange Geschichte und es ist eine interessante Geschichte. Ich rate jedem, der es noch nicht getan hat, sich das mal zu Gemüte zu führen.
Ja, das kann ich auch nur empfehlen, das ist hochklassiger Journalismus, den man auch definitiv damit belohnen sollte, dass man den im Original mal nachliest, liebe Hörer, auch wenn ihr das jetzt vielleicht erst in einiger Zeit hört. Die Kurzpässe sind eine ganze Weile online. Ja, dann lasst mal das Beispiel Cristiano Ronaldo so durchgehen. Ein bisschen grob. Also wir müssen jetzt nicht ins Detail reingehen, weil sehr wahrscheinlich wird es ja gar nicht möglich sein, dass jeder von euch in jedem Detail richtig drinsteckt. Wie arbeitet ihr eigentlich in dem Team? Du hast jetzt von sieben bis neun Leuten allein beim Spiegel gesprochen.
Genau, so ist es. Wenn man so einen riesigen Datensatz vor sich hat, dann braucht man viele Leute, die auch auf ihre Weise spezialisiert sind und Experten sind. Meine Rolle in dem Team ist, dass ich als Datenjournalist eigentlich gerade bei Spiegel online arbeite, aber für dieses Projekt jetzt in das Spiegel-Team mit aufgenommen wurde. Und mein Job war jetzt in den vergangenen Monaten vor allem, die Erkenntnisse, die Recherchergebnisse zu strukturieren, zu sammeln, zu verbinden mit dem, was andere gefunden hatten, zu ordnen und immer ein Ansprechpartner zu sein. Wenn jemand eine Frage hatte und ich das Gefühl hatte, das hatten wir schon mal irgendwo, das haben wir schon mal irgendwo abgeheftet oder das haben wir schon mal irgendwo markiert. Und da könnte es eine Verbindung zu einem anderen Punkt geben. Das war so mein Job. Aber genauso gut haben wir die Rechercheure mit dem absoluten Instinkt, die genau die richtigen Suchergebnisse eingeben und dann was finden und sich dann so lange dran festbeißen, bis sie das Dokument haben, von dem sie vorher noch nicht mal wussten, dass es es gibt, aber von dem sie das Gefühl hatten, das muss irgendwie so etwas in der Art, müssen sie finden, damit es ein ganzes Bild ergibt, damit sich die Punkte zusammenfügen. Dann hatten wir eine begnadete Steuerspezialistin im Team, die sich mit diesen Aufschaugeschichten beschäftigt hat und genau aufdrückte, wo liegen die Probleme in diesem System und was muss Person X versteuern und was ist tatsächlich vielleicht ein Steuerschlupfloch, was ist legal, was ist illegal. Da braucht man einfach extra, was man nicht in so kurzer Zeit aneignen kann. Und so im Team gehören viele weitere Personen, also zum Beispiel dann auch derjenige, der sich dann eine oder zwei Wochen mit meterlangen Aktenordner hinsetzt und daraus dann eine Geschichte schreibt und dafür sorgt, dass dieses Fachlatein, was wir uns irgendwann eingeeignet haben und diese schiere Menge, die wir selbst aus dem Berg rausgeholt haben, was immer noch viel zu viel war, dass man es irgendjemandem erzählen konnte, dass er das aufschreibt und dass er das den Leuten näher bringt, damit sie das wie ein Krimi lesen können. Das war unser Anspruch, gerade auch die Ronaldo-Geschichte ein Krimi ist, ein Sport-Krimi. Ich finde persönlich, das ist meinem Kollegen gelungen und wir haben da auch dahingehend vieles in dem Sinne gehört. Aber das Team endet natürlich nicht beim Spiegel in Hamburg, sondern das ist eine Kooperation mit vielen europäischen Partnern. Das ist das European Investigative Cooperation, EIC Network. Und da haben wir Partner aus Italien dabei, aus Belgien, Holland, Rumänien, Frankreich, Dänemark, Österreich, Serbien, Spanien, ich habe es gleich, England und Portugal. Und mit denen sind wir seit sieben Monaten zugegangen und mit denen tauschen wir uns auf verschlüsselten Plattformen aus und tauschen aus, was wir an Sucherkenntnissen oder was wir an neuen Erkenntnissen gefunden haben und entdeckt haben und wie was zusammenhängen könnte. Wir haben Teams gebildet, die sich zu einzelnen Themenblöcken näher beschäftigt haben und haben uns alle sehr intensiv und nahe kennengelernt in den letzten Monaten. Wir haben viel aufeinander gehockt, wenn auch nur digital mit den europäischen Kollegen oder bei uns hier beim Spiegel in unserem Rechercheraum. Denn das war eine sehr arbeitsintensive Zeit. Ich konnte selbst meinen Fußballpodcast, Eilton Field, nicht weiterführen in den letzten Wochen, weil ich vollends von Footballleaks aufgefressen wurde. Das hat natürlich Riesen-Schwass gemacht. Das hat auch eine Menge Kraft gekostet. Ich bin genauso wie alle anderen sehr froh, dass wir tatsächlich auch letzte Woche starten mit 100.000 Kunden.
Und ohne, dass vorher irgendetwas des Leaks geleakt wurde, wie viele Journalisten in Europa weiter daran beteiligt? Das finde ich erstaunlich.
Ja, wir haben mal versucht, das zu zählen. Wir sind jetzt auf über 60 gekommen, aber selbst beim Spiegel sind es ja viel mehr noch als diese sieben bis neun Leute, die hier zu diesem Rechercheteam gehören. Denn zu irgendeinem Punkt muss man natürlich auch Grafika mit einbinden. Wir hatten Spiegel TV bei einigen Recherchen mit dabei, die auch zum Beispiel mit meinem Kollegen Raphael Buschmann auf die British Virgin Islands geflogen sind und die eine grandiose halbstündige Dokumentation gemacht haben über Footballleaks, die man jetzt übrigens auch auf Spiegel online sich angucken kann. Und letztendlich sind es weit, weit über 100 Leute, die sich in den letzten Monaten damit beschäftigt haben.
Faszinierend und tatsächlich alles kulminierte jetzt am Samstag und eben mit der großen Geschichte unter anderem über Cristiano Ronaldo und jetzt lass mal kurz an dem Beispiel so ein bisschen erklären, worüber wir hier eigentlich sprechen. Also, dass Cristiano Ronaldo viel Geld verdient, das war uns allen schon klar. Jetzt wissen wir auch tatsächlich, wie viel er genau verdient und zwar bis auf den Cent genau, weil ihr eben die original Verträge mit Real Madrid gefunden habt in eurem Datensatz. Und das ist ja aber nicht die eigentliche Geschichte, sondern die eigentliche Geschichte ist doch dann, was passiert mit dem Geld, was er verdient, auch dann über zum Beispiel Wabeeinnahmen.
Um das nochmal hier, diese Zahlen nochmal vorzutragen, wir haben im Text stehen, Ronaldo verdient bei Real 38.181.818 Euro im Jahr. Das mussten wir auch so ausschreiben, weil wenn man diese Zahlen sieht, es wird irgendwann einfach zu abstrakt. Genauso wie man sich diese Terabyte-Zahlen nicht mehr vorstellen kann, kann man sich auch diese Millionenzahlen bei Gehältern und bei Image-Rights, also bei Bildrechtszahlungen, nicht mehr vorstellen. Das ist unvorstellbar, was das für Summen sind. Und wird vielleicht dann ein bisschen konkreter, wenn man in der Doku, die CR7 selber von sich hat machen lassen, sieht, was für Autos er in der Garage stehen hat. Dass er mit seinem Sohn dann das beliebte Spiel spielt, das glaube ich auch jeder von uns kennt, welches Auto fehlt hier. Und dann ist es halt der Lamborghini.
Wir spielen es halt mit Matchbox-Autos.
Und genau wie du aber schon angesprochen hast, es geht bei diesem Offshore-System um die Bildrechte. Das heißt also immer, wenn er Werbung für Unterwäsche macht oder für Armani, glaube ich, hat er Werbung gemacht oder für viele weitere Unternehmen auch, für Emirates zum Beispiel, dann muss das Unternehmen dafür zahlen, dass sie Bilder von ihm, dass sie Fotos von ihm verwenden dürfen. Und sie bezahlen ihn auch dafür, dass er zum Beispiel Autogramme gibt bei Events oder dass er auch nach Pressekonferenz sagt, wie toll er Emirates findet. All solche Deals sind auch bei uns im Datensatz. Da sehen wir, welche Werbepartner mit ihm und mit seinen Bildrecht-Agenturen Verträge abgeschlossen haben. Und da beginnt das System tatsächlich kompliziert zu werden und ich will da auch gar nicht irgendwie tiefer einsteigen, sondern empfehlen sich das bei einer Tasse Kaffee gemütlich zu ziehen und sich das genau durchzulesen. Denn dann geht es darum, was muss man dann eigentlich in welchem Land versteuern? Und wenn diese Bildrechte erstmal bei Irland, wo die Agenturen für diese Bildrechte sitzen und dann offshore auf die British Virgin Islands in der Karibik, wenn da das Geld dann raufgeht, dann ist die Herausforderung herauszufinden, wie viel Geld entgeht da mit der Steuerkasse und wie viel Geld müsste er ansonsten bezahlen, wenn er das alles in Spanien oder Portugal liese?
Ja, genau. Vielleicht kann man sich das so irgendwie ein bisschen versimmbildlichen. Wir haben jetzt einen großen Haufen Schotter. Und die Frage, die sich für sehr reiche Personen und dann wahrscheinlich auch Cristiano Ronaldo stellt und vielleicht ist es tatsächlich auch so eine Herausforderung, die man dann sieht, ist natürlich, wie kann ich möglichst viel von diesem großen Berg behalten? Und das hat dann ganz wesentlich damit zu tun, in welchen Ländern ich diesen Berg horte und wie ich ihn so verschiebe, dass er vielleicht dann für gar nicht mehr sichtbar ist für die in dem Fall dann spanischen Steuerbehörden. Also jetzt in dem Fall wäre es eben so, Cristiano Ronaldo hat über seine Briefkastenfirma von 2009 bis 2014 nach euren Recherchen gerundete 75 Millionen Euro abgewickelt und die sind eben nicht quasi einfach in Spanien bei ihm aufgeschlagen auf dem spanischen Sparkassenkonto und wurden dann dementsprechend versteuert, sondern die wurden eben anders verschoben, so dass sie dann aus dem Sichtfeld des spanischen Fiskuses rausgebraten sind. Und da haben wir ihn, ja.
Er wurde von den spanischen Steuerbehörden auch dein Geld untersucht, also er musste auch eine Steuererklärung machen, ist klar. Und dann ist tatsächlich die Frage, und wir hoffen, dass sich jetzt auch durch unsere Artikel, nicht nur im Spiegel, sondern auch in den anderen Zeitungen und Zeitschriften und Online-Medien in ganz Europa, dass sich dadurch die spanischen Steuerbehörden nochmal ganz genau für dieses Thema interessieren. Denn wenn sie das Gefühl haben, hier ist eine Offshore-Firma, die wurde nur fehlerhaft angegeben oder die wurde komplett ausgelassen, dann müssen sie den Fall womöglich nochmal ganz neu aufholen und sich das nochmal ganz genau angucken und dann womöglich am Ende entscheiden, ob Ronaldo da eine Gesetzlücke sehr geschickt ausgenutzt hat oder ob er tatsächlich etwas Verbotenes getan hat. Denn das maßen wir uns nicht an zu beurteilen. Das ist tatsächlich dann die Sache der Behörde.
Ja, das muss man auch dazu sagen. Nicht alles an diesen Praktiken ist illegal, sondern das sind tatsächlich Schlupflöcher, die genutzt werden können. So war das ja bei den Offshore-Leaks und den Panama Papers auch schon. Vielleicht versuchen wir es mal so halbchronologisch aufzudrösen, dass man es vielleicht auch akustisch so ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann, wovon wir hier sprechen. Bevor Cristiano Ronaldo von Manchester United zur Real Madrid gewechselt ist, hat er schon diese Briefkastenfirma auf den British Virgin Islands, die tollen Assoziates, hat er gegründet und denen seine Bildrechte übertragen, für die nächsten Jahre hinweg. Die Briefkastenfirma über eine Apotheke, das sieht man im Spiegel-TV-Bereich sehr schön. Das ist tatsächlich relativ tragisch, komisch, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es beschreiben soll. Das ist ein sehr eindrückliches Bild.
Auf dieser Insel, genau unten ist ein kleiner Laden, ein kleines Geschäft. Und dann geht es eine kleine Treppe hoch und an dieser Adresse im zweiten Stock sitzt quasi eine Anwaltskanzlei und da sind Hunderte, wenn nicht sogar Tausende, Firmen registriert, die haben noch nicht mal alle einen Briefkasten. Natürlich nicht, das ging ja gar nicht. So groß ist das Haus gar nicht, dass man da für jede Firma einen Briefkasten anhängen könnte. Zumal diese Firmen auch nie Post kriegen. Das ist eine Scheinfirma, das ist genau so sieht eine Briefkasten, eine Offshore-Firma aus.
Okay, also die hat jetzt quasi die Befugnisse mit den Bildrechten von Cristiano Ronaldo zu arbeiten und gibt diese Rechte dann weiter jetzt nicht direkt an Werbepartner wie Nike, Samsung und so weiter, weil Werbepartner sich natürlich, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass so große Unternehmen jetzt nicht so allzu gerne auf ein Konto in den British Virgin Islands etwas überweisen, sondern das hätte man gerne irgendwie anders. Und in dem Fall gibt es dann die Polaris Sport in Irland. Das ist eine Einrichtung, da hängt der Berater dann von Cristiano Ronaldo mit zusammen, aber letztlich auch, korrigiere ich mich wenn es anders ist, auch eine Scheinfirma.
Ja, also das ist, bei diesem Berater handelt es sich um Jorge Mendez. Das ist der, glaube ich, man kann sagen der mächtigste Berater in der Fußballwelt. Der hat sehr viele wichtige, sehr viele große Klienten von Real Madrid und damit auch den größten Spieler überhaupt, Cristiano Ronaldo. Und das ist dieses, das ist das ganze Schema. Das ist das Schema, was alle, die meisten Klienten von Jorge Mendez auch nutzen können. Dieses System mit den beiden irischen Firmen Malti Sports und Image Management und Polaris Sports. Und Polaris wird auch von seinem Neffen verwaltet, also von Jorge Mendez. Das heißt also, das bleibt in dem Sinne dann in der Familie.
Okay. Und was jetzt passiert ist, die handeln jetzt die Sponsorenverträge aus. Das heißt, der Vertrag, der dann mit Nike abgeschlossen wird, zum Beispiel der Sponsorenvertrag, da steht eben dann drin, also das, was ihr mir dafür zahlt, dass ich für euch mein Sixpack in die Kamera halte oder Eightpack, das bekommt bitte dann die Multisport Image Management, also die MEM, die eben die zweite dieser irischer Firmen ist. Und die wiederum schiebt dann das Geld auf die British Virgin Islands und ab dann ist es so ein bisschen aus dem Fokus geraden. Also ich würde fast sagen, kann man sagen, ab dann liegt der Schotterhaufen im toten Winkel und man kann ihn nicht mehr sehen, wenn man nicht interne Dokumente hat, mit dem man diese Geld drüber nachvollziehen kann.
Solange man das alles bei der Steuerbehörde genauso angibt und genau darauf dann auch Steuern bezahlt, wo sie möglich werden, ist da erstmal kein Problem. Aber die Frage ist natürlich, wie man so ein System aufsetzen und warum sollten wir, wie wir in den internen Mails der Steueranwälte von Cristiano Ronaldo gelesen haben, eine gewisse Nervosität ausbrechen, wenn es um Tollin geht bei der Steuerprüfung von Cristiano Ronaldo? Das klingt alles nicht koscher und das lässt ganz stark vermuten, dass da eben mit offenen Karten gespielt wurde.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass er dann erst 2014, also wir erinnern uns, 2009 war der Wechsel und die Gründung dieser Briefkassenfirma und erst 2014 taucht zum ersten Mal ein kleiner Betrag, also für ihn ein kleiner Betrag, 11 Millionen, 11,5 Millionen, in seiner Steuererklärung auf, was viel mit spanischem Steuerrecht zu tun hat. Da hat sich einiges geändert. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, aber um quasi nur zu erklären, was da passiert. Und das heißt, die große Vermutung ist eben ganz viel von dem, was er da eingenommen hat. Das liegt jetzt irgendwo. Man kann es nicht mehr nachvollziehen und es liegt definitiv irgendwo unversteuert. Denn er hat es nicht mit seiner spanischen Steuererklärung der letzten Jahre abgegeben, denn die kennt man oder in die habt ihr ja auch irgendwie Einsicht bekommen. Da taucht das nicht auf. Also Steuervermeidung. Und dasselbe hat er. Er denkt voraus, so wie er vor seinem Wechsel in Suria am Madrid das gemacht hat. So hat er es dann auch schon für die Jahre 2015 bis 2020 gemacht. Das heißt, über Cristiano Ronaldo müssen wir uns keine Gedanken machen. Das beruhigt dann vielleicht auch viele da draußen. Und dann haben wir mit José Mourinho und dann ja auch Charles Mendes, den du auch schon angesprochen hast, zwei weitere Portugiesen. Und das ist ja auch, finde ich, ein ganz interessanter Punkt bei den Footballleaks. Portugiesen oder Spieler, die in Spanien oder Portugal gespielt haben, stehen da so ein bisschen im Fokus. Wie kann man das erklären?
Also die Quelle, den wir nur John nennen, John Doe, das ist halt so wie Max Mustermann. Das war auch bei den Panama Papers der Name für den Informanten da. Und der hat meinem Kollegen Rafael Buschmann gesagt, dass er angefangen hat, Footballleaks zu arbeiten oder Footballleaks aufzusetzen, als er das Gefühl hatte, dass bei Transfers in Portugal irgendwas nicht stimmte und dass da was nicht koscher ist. Und dass er das Gefühl hatte, dass die gesamte Fußballbranche, man neigt ja als Fußballfan gerne dazu, so etwas dann zu generalisieren und das Gefühl zu haben, da liegt so viel im Argen und da sind so viele schmutzige Deals. Und irgendjemand muss da jetzt mal was gegen machen. Und wir suchen jetzt nach der Wahrheit. Und wir brauchen jemanden, der diese Wahrheit erzählen kann. Und deswegen scheint es einen gewissen Fokus auf die Portugiesen zu geben. Wir haben auch schon Klagen gehört, dass wir bisher noch nichts über Spieler vom FC Barcelona veröffentlicht haben. Es war tatsächlich ein Tag, nachdem wir auf Spiegellein groß rausgekommen sind. Und an dem Tag selber, als der Spiegel überall an den Kiosken lag, war der Klassikostand zwischen Barcelona und Madrid. Das hat natürlich noch einmal unheimlich Brisanz reingebracht in die Thematik und unsere Veröffentlichung. Aber das können wir nicht steuern. Wir können nicht zu den Footballleaks-Leuten gehen und sagen, habt ihr nicht auch irgendwas zu Barcelona? Wir haben einfach ein Paket von denen bekommen mit sehr, sehr vielen Daten. Und es ist unsere Verantwortung da, Sachen zu finden. Und natürlich haben wir auch noch anderen Vereinen gesucht.
Ja, das ist jetzt aber vielleicht mal der Punkt, an dem wir tatsächlich ein bisschen über die Herkunft der Daten und auch über die Footballleaks ein bisschen näher sprechen sollten. Also ihr nennt auch in eurem Artikel diesen John. Das ist ein Platzhaltername, hast du schon gesagt. Das ist eine real existierende Person, zu der gelang es, Raphael Buschmann, Ed Raffanelli, bei Twitter Kontakt aufzunehmen. Und von dem hat er auch tatsächlich diese Terabyte an Daten bekommen. Aber John sagt ja selbst, er arbeitet nicht allein. Das heißt, dahinter stehen auch noch andere Menschen. Aber ihr wisst nichts genaues über deren wirkliche Motivation. Denn rein theoretisch könnt ihr euch ja alles erzählen.
Natürlich. Ich vertraue da meinem Kollegen Ed Raffanelli, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, voll ernst. Der hat mit John viel gesprochen und beide haben sich kennengelernt. Und letztendlich geht es für uns dann auch darum, ob diese Daten glaubwürdig sind. Und ich denke, wenn man ein Terabyte-Daten hat und so viele Millionen Dokumente, dann kann man irgendwann davon ausgehen, dass es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass sie gefälscht sind. Das wurde uns von der Gegenseite gerne vorgeworfen, sobald wir die Leute, über die wir geschrieben haben, konfrontiert haben mit unseren Fragen, wie das journalistische Praxis ist. Bevor man etwas veröffentlicht, gibt man der Gegenseite die Gelegenheit, darauf zu reagieren und auf Interviewanfragen zu antworten. Und einige haben uns geschrieben, wir sprechen nicht mit euch, denn ihr habt gehackte Daten und die sind manipuliert. Das wurde ganz oft gesagt. Wir haben John gefragt, ob er die Daten gehackt hat. Er hat gesagt nein. Wir haben ihn gefragt, ob er jemanden damit versucht hat, zu erpressen. Er hat gesagt nein. Er hat uns dieses riesen Datenpaket gegeben und wir haben die Daten sehr genau geprüft. Wir haben uns Unterschriften angeguckt. Wir haben speziell Software eingesetzt, um uns von der Authentizität den Daten zu überzeugen. Wir sind letztendlich am Schluss gekommen, hier will uns keiner aufs Glatteis führen, sondern hier haben wir es tatsächlich mit originärer Datenware zu tun.
Ich würde allein bei der Menge und bei dem, wie jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt reagiert wird auf diese Veröffentlichung, würde ich jetzt auch das Thema der Authentizität nicht infrage stellen. Aber die Frage danach, woher diese Daten kommen, finde ich schon interessant. Also er sagt oder er spricht ja quasi für mehrere, es seien keine Hex und trotzdem stellt sich ja die Frage, das sind, du hast schon davon gesprochen, es sind interne Mails von Anwälten, es sind Spielerverträge, ihr habt Spielerverträge von Borussia Dortmund, von VfL Wolfsburg, von Bayern München. Das sind keine Daten, die einfach so rumliegen und es wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht diesen einen Menschen auf der Welt geben, der all das in seiner Dropbox hat und da irgendwie das Passwort irgendwie admin war. Sprich doch, spricht die Struktur der Daten und die Inhaltsbreite nicht tatsächlich dafür, dass die auf einem mutmaßlich illegalen Weg, einem Hack oder einem Ausspähen irgendwie gezogen wurden?
Es ist ja nicht die erste Leak-Geschichte, das haben wir eben angesprochen, wie gesagt, Offshore Leaks, Panama Papers. Das ist immer eine sehr schwierige Sache, die genau abgewogen werden muss. Man muss sich genau im Klaren sein, mit wem man es da zu tun hat, soweit es irgendwie möglich ist. Und da waren wir sehr beruhigt, dass Raphael auch persönlichen Kontakt zu dieser Person haben konnte und ihn mehrfach fragen konnte, wo er die Daten her hat und was seine Motive sind. Und tatsächlich können wir dann auch nur noch die Antwort weitergeben, die Raphael bekommen hat. Und wir halten das Datenmaterial für authentisch und für so wichtig, dass wir es verwenden und dass wir damit den Lesern und den Konsumenten einen Einblick in die Fußballwelt geben können, die einmalig ist bisher. Und das ist eine Abwägung, die wir natürlich nach langer Zeit, langer Diskussion dann auch so getroffen haben.
Ja klar, das ist keine einfache Entscheidung. Man muss ja auch verantwortlich mit dem umgehen, was man da hat. Ich denke, man sieht es zumindest an den ersten Veröffentlichungen, dass ihr das auch immer im Blick habt. Jetzt ist aber natürlich schon so ein bisschen die Frage, wie geht man mit dem Zustandekommen dieses Leaks ums? Also wir haben hier keinen Edward Snowden, der sein Gesicht in die Kamera hält und auch in seinem persönlichen Schicksal all die Konsequenzen daraus trägt, dass er sich zum Whistleblower-Tum entschieden hat, sondern das ist alles so ein bisschen shady, würde ich fast sagen. Also alles so ein bisschen schwierig.
Das passt tatsächlich auch zu den Akteuren, um die es auch im Leak selber geht. Das wirst du und das werden die Hörer vom Rasenfunk auch in den nächsten Wochen noch erfahren und lesen, dass es da um tatsächlich auch sehr schattige Personen und zwielichtige Gestalten geht, die halt ganz stark und ganz einflussreich im Fußballgeschäft mitmischen und wo man nicht lange braucht, um ein sehr mulmiges Gefühl zu bekommen, die nämlich, wenn es Probleme gibt, nicht unbedingt die Polizei rufen, sondern die Probleme auf ihre Art lösen. Und das klingt sehr nach Mafia und das sage ich auch mit Absicht. Und deswegen ist es dann wahrscheinlich auch die persönliche Entscheidung gewesen von der Person, den Personen, die hinter Footballleaks stehen, das anonym zu machen, um sich selber zu schützen. Und das ist, dass ich, also ich würde mich, ich würde mir das sehr genau überlegen, ob ich wie Edward Snowden den Weg der absoluten Öffentlichkeit wählen würde und sagen würde, hier ist mein Gesicht und das habe ich getan und jetzt muss ich auswandern und jetzt arbeite ich weiter und werde so zu einer zu einer Heldenfigur, aber muss mein Leben, wie ich es bisher gelebt habe, komplett beenden und auch immer darum fürchten, dass die Leute, denen ich da geschadet habe, auf der Suche nach mir sind, um mich zu schädigen. Und das ist dann letztendlich die Entscheidung von Whistleblowern und wir werden natürlich in Teufel tun, dann solche Personen wie Doe oder sei es mal in Zukunft eine Jane Doe dazu zu zwingen oder dazu zu drängen, sich der Öffentlichkeit bekannt zu geben.
Jaja klar, ihr müsst ja auch eine Abwägung treffen, auch zwischen einem öffentlichen Interesse und möglichen moralischen Bedenken. Sei es jetzt eben, dass diese Daten durch einen illegalen Akt eventuell zutage befördert wurden. Dennoch ist das, was darin beschrieben wird, ja nicht unbedingt auch alles legal. Also das ist dann eine klassische Entscheidung des Journalisten oder des Journalistenteams. Ihr müsstet ja auch selber alle möglichen Vorkehrungen treffen, dass ja auch erst gar nicht bekannt wird, dass ihr daran arbeitet. Beschreib mal kurz, wie hat jetzt eigentlich der Spiegel dann diese 1,9 Terabyte, die liegen jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht auf eurem Intranet und jeder kann da drauf kommen.
Nein, das ist natürlich eine eigene Infrastruktur, die dafür erstmal geschaffen wurde. Wir haben einen Rechercheraum eingerichtet, der besonders gesichert wurde. Ich glaube, einige Leute hier wurden dann etwas hellhörig oder haben mal genauer hingeguckt, als wir dann sogar noch Milchglas vor unsere Fenster in den Flur hinein haben installieren lassen, dass halt nicht jeder unbedingt gucken kann, wer sitzt da denn alles gerade an Computern. Wir haben uns eine spezielle Datenforensik-Software zugelegt, mit der man eben gezielt solche großen Datensätze durchsuchen kann und Schnittmengen finden kann und besser und vor allem effektiver arbeiten kann und das alles unter hohen Sicherheitsvorschriften, die wir uns selbst aufüberlegt haben. Wir müssen uns überall mit der Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung einloggen, auch gerade für schlüsselte Plattformen, auf der wir uns mit unseren Partnern in Europa unterhalten. Und das ist alles mit ganz vielen IT- und Sicherheitsexperten und so erdacht worden und so konzeptioniert worden, dass wir eben nicht im Internet landen. Und im Internet landete dann nur letzten Freitag die Meldung, der Spiegel kommt heute nicht um 18 Uhr in der Digitalausgabe auf dem iPad, sondern heute erst um 21 Uhr. Und da haben einige Leute im Haus dann auch tatsächlich das erste Mal erfahren, dass es wirklich jetzt an diesem Abend losgeht. Dass da irgendwas in der Luft ist, natürlich kriegt man das im Haus mit. Aber wir haben versucht, den Kreis derer, die genau Bescheid wussten, sehr klein zu halten.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt die letzten Monate in einem Raum gesessen, ohne Zugang zum Internet. Ehrlich gesagt kann ich mir das gar nicht so wirklich vorstellen. Da würde ich ziemlich nervös werden. Ich will gar nicht wissen, wie sich eure Smartphone-Nutzung seitdem verändert hat. Aber gut, kommen wir mal nochmal zurück. Wir haben jetzt Cristiano Ronaldo. Also er hat Steuern vermieden und da sämtliche Tricks eingesetzt, die man so hat. Und es hat viel damit zu tun, Geldströme verschwinden zu lassen. Etwas Ähnliches. Ich vereinfache jetzt, kann man bei José Mourinho nachweisen. Der musste jetzt dafür auch schon eine Strafzahlung tätigen. Und auch Mesut Özil war jetzt ein Thema eurer Geschichte. Und dadurch, dass es eben ein deutscher Nationalspieler ist, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das Interesse der Hörer an ihm dann vielleicht dann doch noch ein bisschen höher ist. Kannst du grob umreisen, worum geht es denn bei ihm?
Bei Mesut Özil, das hatte ich vorhin schonmal angesprochen, geht es darum, was ganz viele auch Bundesliga-Vereine machen. Wenn sie einen Spieler verpflichten, dann gibt es meistens auch einen Spieler-Agenten, der sich da eingeschaltet hat, der den Spieler angepriesen hat beim Verein zum Beispiel. Meistens ist das ein Spieler-Berater, der halt für, jetzt in diesem Fall, Mesut Özil arbeitet und der dementsprechend dann eigentlich auch von Mesut Özil bezahlt werden sollte, denn er leistet diese Dienste ja für Özil. Jetzt haben aber die Steuerbehörden in dem Fall von Özil entschieden, dass als der Verein die Zahlung für den Spieler-Berater von Özil getätigt hat, dass das nicht rechtens gewesen ist und dass das eine versteckte Gehaltszahlung gewesen sein könnte für Özil. Denn wie gesagt, im Prinzip, die Dienstleistung wird für Özil erbracht und nicht für den Verein. Der Verein profitiert davon, dass er am Ende Özils Unterschrift unter dem Vertrag stehen hat. Aber diese Unterschrift ist zustande gekommen, weil der Spieler-Berater für den Spieler gearbeitet hat und nicht direkt für den Verein. Und wenn der Verein dafür bezahlt, dann könnten damit Steuern umgangen werden.
Noch so ein Seitenstrang der Mesut Özil-Geschichte ist, dass da die Steuerberaterkanzlei, die für sehr viele Spitzenfußballer zuständig ist und eben so ein bisschen im Zentrum dieses Leaks steht, weil mutmaßlich wurde von denen sehr, sehr viele Daten gezogen, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer, dass da noch eine Düsseldorfer Kanzlei mit beteiligt ist und man sich in Spanien ganz schön drüber geärgert hat, wie die arbeiten und dass die den ganzen Ernst der Situation so gar nicht richtig erkannt hätten. Das waren so ein bisschen die Momente eurer Geschichte, wo man fast so ein bisschen schmunzeln musste, muss ich sagen.
Ja, gerade wenn es mal so ein bisschen, ich sag mal, menschelt, ein ganz blöder Begriff, aber ein anderer fällt mir gerade nicht ein. Wenn man dann zum Beispiel liest, dass die Spanischen Anwälte von Özil erleichtert sind, wenn sie erfolgreich verhindert haben, dass aus dem Steuerverfahren ein Strafverfahren wird und damit also größeren Schaden von Özil abgewendet haben, da feiern sie sich dann in der E-Mail und man merkt richtig, wie denen ein Stein vom Herzen fällt. Und das macht diese Materie, die ja sehr trocken, sehr abstrakt sein kann, wo es um viele Zahlen, wo es um Steuerdetails geht, um vielleicht den einen oder anderen Spiegelstrich in einem Gesetz, das Text, das macht das alles wieder so ein bisschen bunter und bisschen begreifbarer. Und das könnt ihr dann auch in der langen Story zu Özil nachlesen.
Jetzt haben wir so mal ein bisschen grob umrissen, was es jetzt erst mal am Samstag zu lesen gab. Wie waren denn jetzt so die Reaktionen danach? Also du hast schon vorhin angesprochen, es gehört zum journalistischen Kodex und es ist ja auch richtig so, dass man alle Beteiligten mit einer Frist vorher informiert und es gab dann, wie haben denn erst mal so die Beteiligten, Vereine, Spieler, Spielerberater usw. reagiert?
Sehr unterschiedlich tatsächlich. Einige Leute haben überhaupt nicht von sich hören lassen. Einige haben auch Fragen geantwortet. Ganz oft bekommt man aber auch das zu hören, was man in der Öffentlichkeit auch zu hören bekommt, wenn man nach Verträgen fragt. Verträge sind vertraulich und über die Ablösesumme oder sonstige Zahlungen ist stillschweigen vereinbart. Dazu beziehen wir keine Stellung. Was aber vor allem unsere Kollegen in Spanien widerfahren ist, ist schon außergewöhnlich, denn die spanische Anwaltskanzlei, um die es hier geht, die hat per Gericht tatsächlich eine einzweilige Verfügung gegen unsere Partner von El Mundo erwirkt. Das steht eben auch mit dem Argument, dass die Daten gestohlen worden seien und deswegen nicht verwendet werden dürfen. Die Chefredaktion von El Mundo hat sich entschlossen, trotzdem zu veröffentlichen, weil sie das als Eingriff in die Pressefreiheit gesehen hat, wenn es Daten, die von öffentlichen Interesse sind, zurückgehalten werden, weil, wie die Kanzlei behauptet hat, die Daten eine zweifelhafte Herkunft haben. Und das ist ein Streit, der jetzt weiter tobt und mit dem es weitergeht und der gerade in Spanien auch natürlich mit den Fällen rund um Cristiano Ronaldo somit mit die höchsten Wellen geschlagen hat. Und da sind wir jetzt auch täglich, weitere Erkenntnisse zu sammeln und weitere Entwicklungen vor allem wahrzunehmen. Heute zum Beispiel haben wir erfahren, dass in Madrid fünf Spieler tatsächlich angeklagt wurden, wegen möglichen potenziellen Steuervergehen und das sind zufälligerweise auch Mendes-Kunden. Da gehört zum Beispiel Ricardo Carvajos zu oder Fabio Coventrao und auch Xabi Alonso zum Beispiel, der jetzt kein Mendes-Kunde ist, aber der beim FC Bayern München spielt. Gegen die ist Anklage erhoben worden, wahrscheinlich auch im Zusammenhang mit den Offshore-Systemen, die zum Beispiel auch Cristiano Ronaldo hat.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen eure Hoffnung, dass mit den Enthüllungen jetzt die Steuerbehörden oder auch sonstigen Behörden, je nachdem in welchem Bereich des Rechts das dann fällt, vielleicht ihre Arbeit aufnehmen, eventuell sogar vergangene Arbeit nochmal neu auffrollen und mit neuen Erkenntnissen jetzt dann auch zu neuen Entscheidungen kommen. Gibt es denn da eigentlich einen direkten Kontakt mit der Justiz?
Nein, das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe. Unsere Aufgabe ist, Missstände aufzudecken, soweit wir sie ermitteln können und soweit wir sie recherchieren können. Unsere Aufgabe ist es nicht, Ermittlungsbehörden mit Material zu füttern. Wenn sie einen begründeten Verdacht erkennen oder ermitteln aus dem, was wir berichtet haben, dann sollten sie selber aktiv werden und selber die Schritte einleiten, die sie für nötig halten. Aber zu viel Nähe wird diesem Verhältnis zwischen Journalismus und Justiz definitiv nicht guttun. Wie gesagt, wir sind rein unsere eigenen Männer und Frauen und berichten über das, was wir hier vorliegen haben und tauschen keine Daten aus, betreiben keine Datenhehlerei.
Also ihr verfolgt in dem Sinne keine Agenda, außer einfach nur aufzuklären über das, was da passiert, was man bisher nicht wissen konnte, weil man auch einfach den Zugang zu diesen Informationen nicht hatte. Und das Verhältnis zwischen Justiz und Journalismus, da muss man sich nur angucken, wie diese Unterlassungserklärung da gegen El Mundo gestaltet ist. Ich habe noch nie von einer Unterlassungserklärung gehört, in der eine Strafandrohung von, ich glaube, bis zu fünf Jahren gegen die Chefredakteure genannt wird. Das ist dann schon ganz schön harter Tobak. Da möchte ich auch nicht in der Haut der Kollegen von El Mundo stecken. Ich bin sehr gespannt, welche Wellen das noch in Spanien schlägt. Wie waren denn die Reaktionen hier in Deutschland?
Das würde mich von dir eigentlich interessieren. Denn das muss ich mir erklären, wir sind halt seit Monaten in diesem Thema drin. Und alles, was wir wahrnehmen, nehmen wir mit dem Hintergrund dessen, was wir schon wissen war. Und ich versuche jetzt hier auch in diesem Podcast irgendwie so verständlich und vielleicht so wenig Kauderwelsch, Fachkauderwelsch wie möglich zu sprechen. Damit ich eben nicht die Leute langweile und irgendwie völlig abgehoben von dem berichte, was für mich irgendwie völlig klar und verständlich ist, aber für andere überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist. Und genauso ist es dann auch mit den Reaktionen, die wir wahrnehmen, da kommt alles dreimal verstärkt mindestens an, weil wir alle so genau darauf warten und gucken, was passiert. Wir haben eine sehr große Resonanz wahrgenommen. Am ersten Wochenende waren meine Kollegen rauf und runter im ZDF und ARD und Deutschlandfunk und WDR interviewt. Und ich habe ganz viele Personen, die sich sonst nie den Spiegel kaufen gehört, die sich bei mir gemeldet haben und gesagt haben, das ist total spannend und gut, dass endlich mal jemand was tut in dieser Branche. Wir wussten ja schon länger, da ist was faul, da ist eh viel zu viel Geld drin und wo so viel Geld drin ist, da muss auch was schief gehen und da müssen krumme Deals gemacht werden und gut, dass ihr jetzt endlich mal da aufklärt. Das haben wir alle wahrgenommen, das haben wir alle gerne gehört. Was wir nicht so gerne gehört haben, ist etwas, das auch sehr oft gesagt wurde, nämlich, ja, das ist doch keine Überraschung. Das ist doch, das haben wir doch alles schon irgendwie gewusst. Gut, jetzt schreibt ihr es noch mal in Detail, aber dass so, dass reiche Leute Steuer vermeiden oder alles dafür tun, dass sie eben nicht auf alles den höchsten Steuer zahlen müssen, das ist doch wirklich nichts Neues. Und ja, komm, die Fußballer, das ist doch eine Riesen-Entertainment-Industrie und die sind eh unantastbar. Da gab es auch den Kommentar auf Zeit Online, wo Oli Fritsch, glaube ich, war es, davon geschrieben hat, dass der Fußball einfach Moral ist, also ein verurteilter Steuersünder, zum Beispiel beim FC Bayern, wird jetzt wieder mit einem SED-Ergebnis ins Amt zurückgewählt und gefeiert.
Und Gegenstimmen werden ausgeboten bei der Jahresaufversammlung.
Genau, zum Beispiel. Und da gibt es so viele Beispiele von der letzten Zeit. Messi natürlich, der große Konkurrent von Cristiano Ronaldo, wurde beurteilt, spielt weiter, wird weiter bejubelt und es hat irgendwie keinen wirklichen Effekt, selbst wenn sie vor Gericht waren und womöglich auch noch im Gefängnis waren. Sobald sie wieder rauskommen, können sie weiter machen und haben weiter ihre Anhänger und ihre Fans. Natürlich ist man rehabilitiert, wenn man im Gefängnis eingesessen hat, aber es sagt ganz viel über dieses System aus. Und wenn Oli Fritsch sagt, der Fußball ist einfach moralisch immun, da kannst du machen, was du willst, da kannst du Footballleaks veröffentlichen noch und nöcher, aber da wird sich nichts daran ändern. Da habe ich dann gelesen auf Twitter, ja Oli Fritsch beendet gerade die Footballleaks. Da sage ich, nein, genau deswegen müssen wir weiter berichten. Genau deswegen muss es solche Projekte weitergeben und genau deswegen muss man ganz genau hingucken, was sind da die Akteure, wer verdient bei welchen Deals, auf welche Weise und wie funktioniert das tatsächlich. Und stellen jetzt mal einen riesigen Scheinwerfer darauf in diese dunkle Ecke und zeigen, was da wirklich los ist.
Mal, welche Kacke Laken da so weglaufen.
Genau und das ist jetzt mein Eindruck und jetzt interessiert mich natürlich, wie man das als Außenstehender wahrgenommen hat, weil ich bin da sehr parteiisch.
Ja, na, du greifst schon ein paar Gedanken, die ich dazu habe vor. Erstmal mein Eindruck der Reaktion, ich habe das auch schon in der letzten Schlusskonferenz thematisiert und zwar ganz am Anfang, weil mir das auch wichtig war und ich wollte, dass das auch wirklich jeder, der dieses Drei-Stunden-Konvolut anhört, auch mitbekommt. Ich war enttäuscht von der Reaktion aus verschiedenen Seiten, und zwar erstmal von Seiten der Fans. Ich persönlich habe viel, viel mehr Aufregung über die Schwalbe von Timo Werner mitbekommen als tatsächlich über die Footballleaks. Ich binde die Hörer im Rasenfunk ja immer sehr viel ein, außer in dieser Folge. Das hat aber viele organisatorische Gründe. War jetzt auch nicht so ganz klar, wann genau wir miteinander sprechen und in welcher Form und wann wir das hier veröffentlichen. Und auch als ich die Hörer eingebunden habe zum Spieltag, da hat niemand Footballleaks auch nur erwähnt. Und ich fand insgesamt die Welle, die das Ganze geschlagen hat, relativ klein. Und das hat für mich so zwei, zwei Erklärungen, die ich so mir geben kann oder vielleicht drei. Das eine ist tatsächlich dann so eine Medienmetaebene. Ich finde, dass tatsächlich relativ wenige Medien da groß mit aufgesprungen sind auf diesen Zug. Ich finde es sehr interessant, einfach mal nach Footballleaks zu googeln und zu gucken, was sind denn da so die News-Treffer, die man findet? Welche Medien haben darüber größer oder kleiner berichtet? Und das sind jetzt nicht 100% alle. Also ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Da kann man jetzt Mutmaßen. Das ist letztlich auch wie gesagt eine Metadiskussion, ob da vielleicht der eine oder andere vielleicht beleidigt ist, dass sein Investigativressort da nicht mitmachen durfte. Aber ich fand allein schon von den Medien her, war es nicht die ganz große Welle. Ich glaube eher wir in unserer Filterblase, die wir uns bei Twitter so mit unseren Influencer-Journalisten-Freunden gebaut haben, wir haben diese Welle sehr, sehr viel größer erlebt, als ich sage mal jetzt einfach der durchschnittliche Sport-1-Doppelpass-Zuschauer. Und das hat aber glaube ich auch noch zwei inhaltliche Gründe, also nicht nur jetzt medientheoretisch, ich glaube, das eine ganz große Problem ist tatsächlich das, was du sagst, was du gar nicht hören willst, dass die Leute sagen, ja das wussten wir doch alles schon. Ich glaube, das ist aber ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt davon, also ich habe das ja auch schon so hier ein bisschen anmoderiert nach dem Motto, naja, das reiche Menschen, dass da anscheinend im Kopf man dann so strukturiert ist, dass man nicht die 80 Millionen auf dem Konto sieht und sich freut und dann auch 14 Millionen Steuern drauf zahlt, sondern dass man die 80 Millionen auf dem Konto sieht und wahnsinnige Angst hat, dass einem davon was weggenommen wird und man das dann vielleicht zu so einer Art Reichensport wird, sein Geld so zu verstecken, dass man davon möglichst wenig teilen muss. Das ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, ein Wesenszug des Menschen, der sehr weit verbreitet ist und den ehrlich gesagt auch jeder bei sich selbst erkennt, wenn er seine Steuererklärung schreibt. Jeder versucht, möglichst wenig Steuern zu zahlen und das ist im Kleinen genau dasselbe wie im Großen. Also warum sollte ich mein Verhalten, was ich schon bei mir entdecke, wenn ich als kleiner Rasenfunk-Moderator meine Steuererklärung mache, warum sollte ich das verlieren, wenn ich irgendwann 100 Millionen Euro verdiene? Es gibt einen Grund, da komme ich gleich drauf zu sprechen und da kannst du nur mal mit Leuten darüber diskutieren, warum sie zum Beispiel aus der Kirche ausgetreten sind. Ganz oft sagen sie, naja ich zahle ja da nicht 8 Prozent sind es glaube ich Kirchensteuer. Ja, ganz ehrlich, na gut, da kommt jetzt noch was anderes mit rein. Aber ich glaube, das ist das eine, also quasi dieses Überraschende oder diese Skandalöse daran fehlt so ein bisschen. Man denkt sich so, irgendwie ist das einem selbst glaube ich dann doch nahe und vielleicht näher, als man lieb ist, dass man sich denkt, naja gut, wenn ich so viel verdienen würde, würde ich es vielleicht auch so machen und gleichzeitig kommt da auch so eine Hilflosigkeit gegenüber dem Tatbestand, dass einfach die Leute, die sehr sehr viel Geld haben, die haben auch viel viel mehr Möglichkeiten dieses Geld zu vermehren und jeder, der sich ein bisschen damit befasst, sieht einfach, die Reichen werden superreich und die Schere klappt immer weiter auseinander und wenn man in der unteren Hefte dieser Schere ist und die untere Hälfte ist halt einfach 90 bis 99 Prozent groß, dann kann man dagegen auch nichts tun. Das heißt, es ist auch so eine Hilflosigkeit. Was soll ich als kleiner Max-Jakob Ost jetzt gegen diese Offshore-Sachen machen? Ich kann es nicht tun und dann, glaube ich, kommt noch so eine zweite Ebene dazu, denn wenn ich jetzt sage, jeder, der seine Steuererklärung ja ähnlich gestaltet, so dass er möglichst wenig zahlt, der erlebt das ja im Kleinen und warum sollte sich das ändern, wenn ich 100 Millionen Euro verdiene, dann gibt es natürlich schon einen Grund, den man da nennen kann, nämlich einfach so etwas wie Bescheidenheit, Moral, Demut oder auch tatsächlich ein Solidaritätswillen. Also Steuern haben ja etwas mit einer Gemeinschaft zu tun, die sich gegenseitig trägt und da sollten vor allem eigentlich, der Theorie nach, sollten die, denen es besonders gut geht, da einen besonders großen Anteil tragen, um die zu tragen, denen es besonders schlecht geht. Das wäre eigentlich so der Grundgedanke und genau das Gegenteil passiert aber.
Das wird ganz schnell eine moralische Diskussion.
Genau. Und ich glaube, das ist aber tatsächlich auch ein Problem. Also ich habe einen Kommentar gelesen von Nicole Selmer, der Chefredakteurin von Ballesterer. Die hat auch unter anderem dem Spiegel vorgeworfen, wie, ich verkürze jetzt, sehr moralin sauber die Art und Weise der Berichterstattung ist. Das heißt, dass immer betont wird, welche gewaltigen Unsummen das sind und ebenso das moralische dahinter hervorgekehrt wird. Und ich persönlich würde das gar nicht so verurteilen, denn ich glaube, es braucht diese Ebene. Ich glaube, das ist die eine Ebene, auf der man die Leute noch packen kann, weil du ansonsten zu wenig emotionalen Zugriff auf die Menschen bekommst. Und dann gleichzeitig noch diese, dass es so ein bisschen aus einer kriminologischen Sicht herrausgeschrieben ist, ist es tatsächlich auch einfach spannend, diese Artikel zu lesen. Und man denkt sich dann, ja, Wahnsinn. Also unglaublich einfach, wie abgehoben auch von jeder Lebensrealität da manche Akteure sind, weil die sich quasi in so einem vollkommen abstrusen Universum bewegen, in dem auch tatsächlich die Maßstäbe von Recht und Ordnung und Richtig und Falschheit einfach, die haben andere Maßstäbe als jetzt wir zwei wahrscheinlich. Und ich glaube, das sind so die wesentlichen Aspekte, die da zusammenfließen.
Ja, und ich denke auch, es ist wichtig, dass wir diese Riesensummen nennen und das wird dann ganz schnell auch als Neid missverstanden, wie ich finde. Denn letztendlich müssen wir versuchen, diese Summen begreifbar zu machen. Das ist für Cristiano Ronaldo einfach auch mal in Worten ausgeschrieben bei uns im Text. Weil das allein, was er in einem Jahr verdient, so unendlich viel mehr ist, als das, was wir in unserem ganzen Leben verdienen werden. Und da sind einfach jegliche Verhältnisse flöten gegangen, Größenverhältnisse, die es sich vorher mal gegeben hat. Und das natürlich genau diese Kategorie immer weiter reinhaut seit Jahren, wenn man sich die Entwicklung der Fußballbranche anguckt. Und das sind ja schon reine Binsen, wenn man sagt, es ist immer mehr Geld im System, es ist zu viel Geld im System. Und jedes Jahr werden die Ablösesumme absurder und die Fernsehgelder, das nimmt wieder irre und astronomische Summen an. Und es gibt vor allem in Deutschland doch kein öffentlicheres Interesse als Fußball. Also jeder verfolgt doch die Weltmeisterschaften, die deutsche Meisterschaft dann als Fußballfan.
Aber wir lieben es halt auch so, Christoph. Das ist ja das Problem. Das Problem merke ich ja sogar an mir selbst, der ich als Bayern-Fan sehe, viele Dinge im Verein kritisch sehe. In der Sekunde, in der ich im Stadion stehe, sehen die Laufende unten aufs Spielfeld, ist mir das ehrlich gesagt dann auch nicht mehr so wichtig, dass der Flughafen von Doha gerade Sponsor geworden ist. Da will ich einfach nur, dass die gewinnen.
Und das ist ein urromantisches Gefühl.
Das braucht man ja auch.
Und diese Romantik, glaube ich, herrscht in weiten Teilen wahrscheinlich nur noch bei den Fans und meistens nicht mehr. Man verliert zumindest die Glauben daran, wenn man Spieler über ihr Tor jubeln sieht, wenn man weiß, dieser Spieler bekommt für sein Tor auch nochmal eine 5-stellige Summe. Der freut sich jetzt natürlich wahrscheinlich, dass er seinem Team geholfen hat und er freut sich auch, dass er von 80.000 Leuten bejubelt wird. Aber er weiß auch, es hat gerade Katsching gemacht auf seinem Konto.
Ja, aber das ist doch ehrlich gesagt sowohl dem Spieler als auch dem Fan in dem Moment egal. Mir geht es ja tatsächlich nur darum, dass der gerade das 1 zu 0 geschossen hat in dem wichtigen Spiel. Ist das nicht vielleicht eher der Kern der Sache, dass man es nicht mehr auf denjenigen. Geht und hat Barca und Realfans interviewt und da gab es ja auch welche, die gesagt haben, der soll so viel verdienen, wie er will, das ist einfach der geilste Fußballer aller Zeiten. Da bist du mit Argumenten machtlos.
Das Kamerateam hat einem Fan, ich glaube sogar von Barcelona, den Vertrag von Ronaldo mit dieser tollen Associates von den Offshore-Inseln in die Hand gedrückt. Guck mal, das ist der Vertrag. Und der Fan von Barcelona, wie gesagt, hat gesagt, das glaube ich nicht, dass der Ronaldo so etwas macht. Und Fußball ist nie rational, natürlich, gerade nicht bei den Fans. Aber es muss uns auch bewusst sein, dass da tatsächlich sehr rational und sehr kapitalistisch gedacht wird, bei allen Beteiligten, die im Fußballgeschäft involviert sind. Und die machen sich natürlich die Irrationalität und die Emotionalität der Fans zu. Das ist doch völlig klar, das ist ein gutes Geschäftsmodell und das machen die verdammt gut. Das ist eine tolle Entertainment-Show, die wir alle genießen. Vor allem diese Saison, wo es ja endlich mal wieder spannend wird, eine kleine Spitze an den Bayern-Fans.
Endlich mal wieder.
Aber natürlich, warum wird es spannend? Wegen RB Leipzig. Und das Fass müssen wir jetzt nicht nochmal aufmachen. Aber ich glaube, das ist einfach nur nochmal ein Stichwort, um anzudeuten, was natürlich auch hinter Footballleaks, also bei Footballleaks immer mitschwingt. Das ist genau dieses Gefühl, da entfernt sich etwas so schnell, so rapide von uns, von den normalen Leuten, dass wir Angst darum haben, wie der Fußball in drei, vier, fünf oder zehn Jahren überhaupt aussieht.
Die melken unsere Liebe, jetzt etwas populistisch formuliert.
Das klingt wie so ein Verein, so etwas wie echte Liebe oder wir leben dich. Wir melken eure Liebe.
Ja, ein bisschen ist es doch so. Also tatsächlich sind ja auch diese Summen, die so hoch sind, die sind ja auch tatsächlich nur refinanzierbar, weil tatsächlich wir Fans auch so viel Kohle für den ganzen Kram springen lassen. Also diese Geldströme refinanzieren sich ja irgendwie. Warum zahlt Nike an seine Testimonies Millionenbeträge? Ja nur, weil sie auch entsprechende Fußballschuhe etc. und so weiter darüber verkaufen.
Die Ticketpreise in englischen Stadien sind eine Unverschämtheit. Die sind so unfassbar hoch, die Stadien sind trotzdem ausverkauft. Irgendjemand kann sich das dann mitziehen und seufzt dann halt, aber sagt, ja es ist auch mein Verein.
Ja genau, es ist halt einfach ein geiles Spiel und es ist eine geile Sportart und es sind auch gute Kicker. Aber gleichzeitig müsste man halt häufiger noch klar machen, dass viele Dinge, also es gibt ja schon auch Dinge, die in breiteren Fankreisen auch kritisiert werden am Fußball. Aber da ist jetzt Rhabar Leipzig ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür und das hängt alles mit denselben Mechanismen zusammen, nämlich letztlich reduziert sich es ehrlich gesagt auf Kapitalismus und auf Kohle und da sind natürlich dann solche Machenschaften im Halblegalen dann schon wieder interessant, weil sich da Leute dann einen weiteren Wettbewerbsvorteil verschaffen oder eben ja wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht bei unserer Recherche, dass wir ganz viele Fälle aufgedeckt oder erlebt haben oder nachvollziehen konnten.
Wir merken, je dreister jemand in einen Deal gegangen ist und versucht hat, das Maximum für sich rauszuholen, desto erfolgsversprechender am Ende auch. Und es ist doch kein Wunder, wenn man sich anguckt, was in den letzten Jahren mit UIFA viel verpasst ist, wer da alles verhaftet wurde und für was, dass man da kein großes Vertrauen hat, dass da noch die Regulation funktioniert. Regulierung heißt es.
Und gleichzeitig sind ja zum Teil, Teile dieser Methoden sind ja auch wirklich legal. Das ist ja dann tatsächlich nur mal ein Riesenproblem, es gibt halt einfach sehr, sehr kleine Meistinseln, die sich da ein eigenes Geschäftsmodell aufgebaut haben, keine Unternehmenssteuer zu verlangen. Aber über andere kleinere Peanut-Abgaben, dann bei 10.000 Briefkastenfirmen, summiert sich das dann so wieder zusammen, dass man als British Virgin Islands zum Beispiel dann ganz gut über die Runden kommt.
Genau, und mit dem, was ich eben gesagt habe, meinte ich auch nicht nur Offshore-Geschäfte, also ganz im Gegenteil. Wir haben ja jetzt letzte Woche mit dem Spiegel eine Veröffentlichungs-Serie begonnen.
Genau, sag mal, was noch so kommen wird. Am liebsten kannst du mir jetzt natürlich das sehr detailliert sagen. Ich vermute mal, du musst da vage bleiben, aber deute mal so ein bisschen an, auf was kann man sich so bewegen.
Das habe ich quasi gerade schon, denn es wird im weiteren Verlauf darum gehen, wer an Deals partizipiert und wie das vollzogen wird und was es da für Absprachen gibt und wie Spieler zum Beispiel auch von Beratern und von Vereinen. Also wir gehen jetzt von dieser Steuergeschichte ein Stückchen weg und steigen in die Niederungen der Berater-Verträge zum Beispiel ein.
Oh, sehr interessant, da freue ich mich, dass ich gehofft bin, einiges zu wissen. Was erhofft, da musst du jetzt einfach für dich sprechen, was erhoffst du dir denn jetzt, dass sich verändert? Glaubst du tatsächlich, dass das zu großen Veränderungen führen kann im Fußball?
Was ich persönlich glaube, ist, dass in Deutschland, wahrscheinlich auch in ganz Europa, es nicht mehr lange so weitergehen kann. Vielleicht darf, vielleicht kann es weitergehen, ja, aber vielleicht darf es so nicht weitergehen. Und ich fände es mal wirklich ein sehr interessantes Gedankenexperiment, was bestimmt auch nicht nur von mir bisher gemacht wurde, mal zu überlegen, wie das im amerikanischen Profisport funktioniert. Das wären dann so heilige Kühe, die hier geschlachtet werden müssten mit der 50-1-Regel und darf jemand einen Verein, tatsächlich eine Privatperson, einen Verein übernehmen. Die Elf-Freunde hatte, glaube ich, im aktuellen Magazin da ein paar schöne Beispiele für, wenn irre Personen einen Verein übernehmen, was dann alles schiefgehen kann. Das wäre sehr schlitzam, aber es ist deutlich weniger verlogen als das, was jetzt auch in der Bundesliga passiert. Und wer da wie die Hände mit drin hat im operativen Geschäft, nur weil er der größte Geldgeber ist, nur in Anführungszeichen, natürlich, Geld ist alles in diesem Geschäft, da kann einem manchmal Angst und Bange werden. Und das wissen ja auch die Fans. Also ich als Fan von Borussia Dortmund kann natürlich wunderbare Sprüche über Gazprom oder Clemens Tönnies reißen, aber weiß genau auch, dass meine Freunde, die Blaufans sind, auch ihre Probleme haben mit diesen Geldgebern und mit den Leuten, die da Entscheidungen fällen können. Und das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel von so vielen Vereinen, wo ganz viel schief läuft und wie gesagt nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern in Europa. Das ist im Moment eine ganz ungute Entwicklung und das wird auch gebühlenartig von allen Leuten wiederholt, dass sie sich eigentlich die Romantik zurückwünschen. Das ist ein Wunschdenken, was nicht ganz erfüllt werden kann. Ich meine, früher war eh immer alles besser. Aber tatsächlich muss man wahrscheinlich das ganze System grundlegend ändern. Und da habe ich nicht das Patentrezept dafür. Aber ich glaube, früher oder später wird es so weit kommen, dass da etwas komplett geändert werden muss.
Transfarenz wäre schon mal ganz gut. In NBA, in NFL, da weiß ich, wie viele Millionen jemand bekommt. Das hängt natürlich auch mit dem Category-Cap zu tun, aber das wäre vielleicht auch gar nicht so die schlechteste Idee. Aber tatsächlich ist es ja mal ganz interessant zu wissen, dass dann auch Lavetzi der aktuell bestverdienendste Spieler der Welt ist, weil er in China irgendwie für 23 Monate, ich glaube 50 Millionen oder so, nagelmäßig nicht auf die Summe festbekommt.
56,7 Millionen.
56,7 Millionen. Ach Wahnsinn. Wenn man sich dann mal ausrechnet, wie viele 10.000 Jahre man selbst dafür arbeiten müsste, dann das finde ich ein ganz guter Bezugsrahmen tatsächlich.
Er hat ja auch vor seinem Wechsel betont, dass er andere Angebote dafür ausgeschlagen hat, weil er sich für die chinesische Kultur interessiert.
Klar, die haben ganz besonders tolle Geldzellmaschinen. Aber gut, gleichzeitig sind wir dann auch schon wieder in so einer Ecke, wo man halt sehr moralin sauer ist und bei mir ist es jetzt ehrlich gesagt kein Neid auf den, der muss in der chinesischen Liga Fußball spielen. Aber man könnte mir natürlich auch neid unterstellen. Es ist tatsächlich schwierig, dieses Thema zu transportieren, ohne immer mit der riesigen Moralkeule zu kommen oder als Neidharmel dazu stehen oder Dinge zu verharmlosen. Also schwierige Sache, schwierige Sache. Christoph, ich hab dich schon länger in Beschlag genommen, als du mir eigentlich versprochen hattest und ich weiß ja, dass Zeit gerade ein wichtiges Gut ist. Aber ich hab noch eine brennende Frage. Hast du mal in eurer Forensik-Software Rasenfunk eingegeben?
Nein, hab ich tatsächlich noch nicht. Vielleicht ist uns da die große Schweinerei entgangen.
Ach so, ne, das nicht, keine Angst. Nein, aber mich würde interessieren bei 1,9 Terabyte Daten, E-Mails und so weiter, ob irgendeiner von denen den Rasenfunk kennt.
Ailton fehlt einfach, steht auch nicht drin. Das weiß ich zumindest nicht.
Hätte ich aber an deiner Stelle auch gemacht, sehr, sehr cool. Ja, wenn du mir einen Gefallen tun kannst, dann kannst du das ja vielleicht mal machen. Gut, im spanischen Markt sind wir vielleicht noch nicht so verbreitet und das haben wir ja schon besprochen, dass da noch ein Schwerpunkt ist. Ich bin da zuversichtlich. Aber vielleicht ist ja einer von denen sogar Rasenfunk-Supporter. Dann finde ich den ganz gut. Man kann uns ja auch unterstützen.
Sag doch nochmal die Domain, wo man das machen kann.
Ich habe es mir gerade verkniffen, weil ich mir dachte, das ist jetzt ganz schön. Die Leute werden es finden, die sich dafür interessieren. Christoph, vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank, dass du dir diese Zeit genommen hast. Und wie gesagt, länger als eigentlich vereinbart. Ich sage nochmal, dass man dir auf Twitter folgen kann. Edder Henrichs.
Genau.
Man kann auch eton fehlt hören, das sollte man auch tatsächlich tun, wenn du halt dann irgendwann auch mal wieder Zeit für deinen eigenen Podcast hast.
Ja, ich glaube, ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen verdorben für meinen Fußballpodcast. Denn mein Prinzip mit meinem Kollegen Matthias, wenn wir uns vor dem Mikro gesetzt haben, dann haben wir uns einfach über Fußball unterhalten, wie wenn wir uns in der Kneipe treffen und um Fußball quatschen. Und da sind auch gerne dann mal ein paar Halbwahrheiten oder eine Menge Blödsinn auch mit dabei. Und jetzt ist man auch bei einigen beäutert, wenn man hier die Fakten kennt. Aber Ailton Field einfach wird es auch in Zukunft in irgendeiner Form irgendwann wieder geben.
Ja, das ist schön und wir werden einfach alle damit umgehen müssen, wie sich der Fußball gerade verändert. Alle Fußballfans da draußen. Christoph, vielen herzlichen Dank noch mal. Ed der Henrichs bei Twitter. Mein Name ist Maxer Kuopost. Ed Genetzer bei Twitter. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, liebe Zuhörer. Und Glückwunsch an Raphael Buschmann. Vielleicht hört er das ja irgendwie. Ed Raffanelli. Toller Leak. Ich bin gespannt, wie oft wir das im Rasenfunk noch thematisieren dürfen. Wenn es nach mir geht, sehr häufig. Christoph, vielen, vielen Dank dir.
Wir geben uns Mühe. Danke schön.